it isn't good what the media is doing
and that I do have the right to fight
back on the campaign trail you called
yourself a nationalist some people saw
that as embolden white nationalist
that's such a racist question I would
never do that and I don't use racist
remarks quiet it's people like this that
cause division one of the statements
that you made in the tail end of the
campaign there we go that honestly I
think you should let me run the country
you run CNN and if you did it well your
ratings let me ask one of the other
folks that said now pardon me ma'am mr.
president that's enough this president
right the other folks that said enough
for me ma'am
you are a rude terrible person you mr.
president in Peter Gunn in Jim's defense
I've traveled with him and watched him
he's a diligent reporter who's I'm not a
big fan of yours either so I understand
to be honest
you